alexej nawalny der kreml kritiker putins
erzfeinden nummer eins der bei uns in
deutschland war hat deutschland
verlassen ist nach russland geflogen
und wir können jetzt sprechen mit meinem
kollegen peter tiede der mitgeflogen ist
und wir sehen ihn im flugzeug peter
konntest du mittlerweile sprechen wasser
ist auf deinem weg alles passiert heute
spreche ich mit alex herein die jetzt im
moment niemand wir sind jetzt gerade in
moskau angekommen und es geht völlig
geräuschlos wird die maschine ist unter
vorwänden umgeleitet wo es nicht zu
gewalt dem alten moskauer flughafen
gelandet sondern die ist gelandet auf
dem großen flughafen iq der grund ganz
einfach genug war
da warten die anhänger von alexei
navalny zu erwarten da war dem publikum
da waren auch russische und unser sturm
listen und ein teil der welt das sich
eben aus koordiniert sind
deswegen ist mir die maschine umgeleitet
worden alexander waren die sitze mit
seiner frau zusammen und mit seiner
sprecherin
in der halle 13 gesetzte abc es ist ein
großer teil dann auch von journalisten
44 mit im zeugnis
wir sehen hier die antwort von alexei
navalny er ist mit anzahl limousinen mit
der bundesregierung zum flughafen
gebracht worden und ist dann in die
maschine eingeschnitten nach einen
anderen mann an bord es gab vereinzelte
applaus selbst regisseur dessen haben
sich mit ihm fotografieren lassen also
der mann liegt hier fünf monaten noch
hinkommen ich sage mit einem
mordanschlag verübt worden ist geht er
zurück nach moskau zurück in russland in
das land in dem man ihn umbringen will
in dieser stadt jagt optimal gemacht hat
und ihn mit dem roboter da gibt's dann
seine konten sind gepfändet worden
der staat hat ein fall unter
fadenscheinigen gründen auch wieder
einfach fragen gegen ihn begonnen und es
wird fest damit gerechnet dass alles in
der welt heute spätestens morgen wieder
kurzzeitig zum linie in gewahrsam
genommen wird dass er verhört wird und
dass er es weiterhin nicht einfach haben
wird also der mann fliegt wirklich fast
schon todesmutig zurück in seiner heimat
den start der jagd auf ihn macht indem
sie das ja so gut wie kein echter
kremlkritiker also kein
oppositionsführer überlebt hat diesen
bisher alle tot sind erschossen worden
oder auf andere weise sind
gestorben sind sie gestorben jetzt
alexander weile zurück und das ist
wirklich mutig und er sagt auch dass er
dass er zurück muss und es ist auch es
ist doch völlig normal weil er kann auch
deutschland seine wirkung nicht
entfalten
und jetzt muss sich der kreml das muss
er sich jetzt mal trauen jetzt noch mal
auf alle center war in die loszugehen
das ist fast unmöglich mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren